Hey, welcome back to 40 Days of Holiness.
Today, I want to encourage you to grab a hold of a workbook, and we're
going to talk about what holiness means.
The Bible is full of pictures. It gives lots of
metaphors. It's not primarily a definitions book or
a philosophical meanderings book. Jesus told parables.
He told picture stories. God gives us word pictures.
And for the next 10 days, I'm going to focus on a lot of the
positive statements, the metaphors, the pictures of what it means
to be holy.
Now, the other day we said it's more than subtraction.
Today, we're starting with the positive pictures of what it does mean.
Today's theme is Holiness Means Loving God With All Your Heart.
Matthew 22:36 says this: "Teacher, which
is the greatest commandment in the law?" And Jesus replied, "Love the Lord your God
with all your heart, with all your soul, and with all your mind.
This is the first and greatest commandment.
And the second one is like it, love your neighbor as yourself.
All the Law and the Prophets hang
on these two commands."
Jesus, in response to this question, gives
us the idea that loving God is the
first and the most important, the most comprehensive
command in all of scripture. Every other command flows
out of it and depends on this one.
Now, this is important at this moment that we take a moment and recognize what
it means
to love God. Because we only have one word for love in English, and it has this
huge range of intensity, right? I love pizza and I love my wife.
I love my phone and I love Jesus.
And those two are not the same, right?
John Wesley gives what I think is probably the best definition that I've ever heard
of loving God with all of our heart.
Here's what he says: "What is it to love God, but to delight in him,
to rejoice in his will,
to desire continually to please him, to
seek and find our happiness in him, and to
thirst day and night for a fuller enjoyment of
him?"
That is marvelous, isn't it? All Christians agree that this is
the primary thing, and all Christians also agree that this is hard,
even after we're saved. Why is that? Here's why.
Because our heart is still divided.
This is clear enough from scripture and from experience.
And remember when we said a few days ago that you were going to need to put on
your possibility glasses instead of your depravity glasses to read the scripture?
Right? This is where you're going to need them.
You're going to need to put on the right set of glasses because here's what
most Christians do with this. "Well, there's one more command
I'll never be able to keep till I get to heaven." Right?
"I guess I'm never going to be able to do that.
Can't love the Lord with all my heart."
You recognize that, right? It's depravity glasses.
It's reading the commandments of God with exactly the same
attitude and exactly the same amount of hope as a non-Christian who wishes they
could do right, but can't.
It is my conviction that if Jesus commands us to love him with
all of our heart, that he was, are you ready?
Completely sincere and willing to grant the power to
do it.
Not through our teeth-gritting self-control, but through the power of
the indwelling, purifying Holy Spirit's work.
So here's a beautiful thing I want you to believe.
The greatest assurance you can do something is that God has
asked it of you.
If we look at that verse with these glasses, we would say, "Oh,
look at the possibilities of grace.
Look what's been granted to God's children by their Father."
The world and the flesh and the devil are
constantly raising up other things to tempt us to place our love
upon them, things we would call them idols, idolatry.
And holiness means rejecting those idols offered by the world,
the flesh, and the devil, and keeping our love fixed
upon Christ. It means a heart that is whole and
undivided.
My friend, Dr. Phil Brown says, "Our creator, who knows our design
and empowers our inner life, will not command the
impossible."
That's beautiful. See, that's why we can get here to loving God with
all our heart, because the whole Trinity is involved in creating holiness
in you. As the Father, he wills it in eternity past, Ephesians
1, right? As the Son, he provides it on the cross, Hebrews
13. As the Spirit, he executes it from
within our hearts. Oh my goodness, so many scriptures.
So
what does this mean? Does this mean I'm never going to mess up?
Loving God with all your heart means that there's no problems? Well, no.
Wholehearted love,
it affects performance, but it's not the same thing as perfect performance.
Let me give you a quick illustration that my dad told me one time.
My dad was out washing the 40-foot travel trailer
that we had. He was washing it. We were living in it at the time,
and he was up on a ladder in like 85-degree
weather and was washing and waxing the trailer.
My little sister, who was, oh, probably five at the
time, had been out playing on the church grounds,
and she had gone and played in the church bus, and she was coming back,
and she had found, he didn't know, but she had found a cup in the church bus.
And she was carrying that cup, and she went inside the house and got some ice in it
and put some water in it, and she came back out of the trailer,
and she looked up, and she saw her daddy, and he was waxing the trailer
And she said to him, "Daddy, would you like a drink?"
And he said, "I sure would." So he climbed down off the ladder,
reached over, and she, with sparkling eyes and happy face,
she handed him the water. And he said, "I took it, and just as I began to raise
it to my lips, I looked down inside it."
And he said, "I don't know what it was floating in there, but
something wasn't right with this glass of water."
And he said, "But at that moment," he said, "I had a couple of choices.
I could say, 'I don't want your water.
If you can't do better than that, I don't want it.
Bring me some clean water.'"
But he said, "Instead,
I looked down into it, and I looked past, and I saw the
sparkling eyes of a little girl who wanted nothing
more than just to please her dad,
just to make him happy,
and just to give him a drink."
And he said, "I saw past imperfect performance,
and I saw pure motive."
What God wants to give you
is not something that will always create perfect performance in you.
Instead, what he wants to do is give you such a
participation in the inner life of the Trinity
that your motivation is purified to love him with all your
heart.
So that your motivation is purified to
be a desire to continually please him,
seek and find our happiness in him, thirst day and night for a fuller enjoyment of
him.
And so that's what we're aiming for. That's what we're trying for.
That's what we're headed toward. So tomorrow, we're going to continue talking about
how God produces that in our hearts.
That's the first metaphor, the first word picture that the Bible gives us
of holiness, loving God with all your heart.
See you back here tomorrow.